teach me about songwriting a little bit
because i have to go home and write a uh
album i'm sick of this come on you know
you're just
aiken to change places for me well i am
i mean who doesn't want to be a rock
star isn't it the greatest i just always
wanted to be sort of like a a radio
personality that's really what i've been
working on but elvis isn't it a great
experience in life to be able to stand
on a stage with a guitar it's so cool
and to to have great songs and watch
people mouth them along i would think is
it is there a better high than that
well of course it's it's it's curious
when people after so many years want to
hear the song you started out with it's
but you got to take it in a good part
and then it's your responsibility to
make sure you do that song as well as
you can is it hard to do that now when
someone says to you
i worked out how to do it for some years
i struggled i wrote in the book that
when we were first in america like the
first couple of times we came we came
once and it was like a big
to-do about it or so we felt you know we
we went and played the whiskey go go on
the bottom line and we thought we'd made
it you know yeah we actually dropped the
song alison out of the set because i
thought it was making it too easy for
people to like us right you know i
thought well that's because that's a
likeable song i wanted to make it harder
but it was i was 22. you know
right i mean you you have to think then
you know you have an attitude you want
to be rebellious in a way and you're
like hey [ __ ] you you want me to play
people to like you want me to play
allison i [ __ ] you i'm going to play
something else you know what i mean it's
like this each new song you write is at
that time was like okay this one's
better than the last one so you gotta
hear this one and it's how we got in the
trouble when we went on saturday night
live because record company wanted me to
play a song off the first record that
was you know and still this this clip
gets shown and talked about particularly
any time anybody does anything
outrageous on that show they we get a
bit of free publicity out of it and it's
so weird to me that you decided to play
a different song and that was so
outrageous
i mean come on yeah live is in the name
of the show right it's like a bit of a
clue it's it it really wasn't that big a
deal yeah
and in retrospect people have written
about it afterwards but you know but
nobody saw that because nobody had a vcr
then but tell me something when you go
on saturday night live and then there's
all this controversy you decided in the
beginning of the song [ __ ] you i'm not
gonna play the song i'm gonna play a
different song
i'm sorry ladies and gentlemen there's
no reason to do this song here and then
lauren michaels and everyone at nbc is
pissed off at you does that stay with
you are you nervous at all inside or are
you just like i don't give a [ __ ] what
these people think at all
i don't think that
lorne says after the fact now that that
he he didn't really care what we did ask
my scrap was really with the rec company
because there was going on about this
one song i didn't think we needed to
play right and we just did what we
wanted and and yes they went no you'll
never come in here again and they didn't
go on tv for a couple of years but
you know people think i'm still banned i
was on the show 12 years later i
i was you know i was on the 25th
anniversary show with the beastie boys
for heaven's sake doing a
skit based on that night at that time
because you're a young guy and it seems
like it's such a big brouhaha yeah you
didn't sit and sweat that in other words
you didn't sit there and get nervous
that you ended your career or something
so we were back on the plane to england
and we hadn't we had a couple of days
off and we had another 20 30 shows to
play and you laugh it off right it's
just like hey you screwed i mean it was
everything everything you know we were
in our own little place and getting the
bus and drive away you know isn't it
amazing elvis that those things that are
controversial at the time are the very
thing that like now that clip is always
played like that's the thing that
defines you on saturday night yeah in
some ways that's what the shows want is
moments that stick out you know but but
of course it's a bit different now
because if you did something like that
it would be on social media the next day
right then it was just what they wrote
about in the paper yeah people said
hearsay and if you added up all the
people that claim to have seen it that
you know they would have filled madison
square gardens i don't know that that
many people could have been watching you
know